because if you're stuck in the
wilderness you can die there
people don't understand you have to get
inside of the sanctuary to live
with all this talk about the third
temple is a sanctuary message still
relevant today
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome back to
led live we are with tila
brad and darius you know what i've
always had a question is the sanctuary
still relevant today because i mean
there's so much going on in the
sanctuary and there's even people saying
they want to rebuild the sanctuary sure
what's up with that is is it is the
message are you gonna go and uh start
killing lambs again
what's the deal with this
well believe it or not according to
scriptures the sanctuary is actually
pretty relevant today um
specifically uh when we focus on
scriptures uh given by the psalmist
david
uh and we continue here he says in
psalms 7 7 13 he says thy way o god
is in the sanctuary
so we we have here presented to us
that the way to righteousness or the way
to the father is through the sanctuary
which is surrounded around around the
plan of salvation
focusing on christ
in psalms 73 verse 17 it says
again the psalmist speaks he says until
i went into the sanctuary of god then i
understood their end so here we see
that there is information that's
provided in the sanctuary that is not
known to a lot of people within the
world unfortunately uh
many churches uh focus on the cross and
yes this is very important but a lot of
people stop there but if we study the
sanctuary we can see that there is still
a work that's going on in the heavens
yeah i just wanted to say something
that's kind of interesting
um where it says
thy way oh god it's in the sanctuary and
if we we look at christ's words right he
says
i am the way the truth and the life and
we know that the truth is permanent
so that's that's also another reason why
the way or the sanctuary is relevant
today because it's permanent
wow
i wonder what it said until i went to
the sanctuary
of that i understood
so it's like so interesting if we don't
study the message of the sanctuary
kind of like we don't understand what's
going on of the salvation so it seems
like the
sanctuary message is more
of salvation
yeah and and not to get a in front of
your study but i from what i understand
about the sanctuary it didn't just end
with a slaughtering of the lamb and
jesus is the lamb of god right
so there must be more to what's going on
right now because we haven't gotten to
heaven yet right so something else is
happening what's what's going on so i
believe to understand exactly what's
going on in heaven we have to
look at the past
and we're presented with the story of
moses
and um of course moses
enters into the mount with with god and
he's there for a a period of time and
many people who are familiar with this
story they tend to focus on the
commandments being given to moses but
not actually focusing on the other
things that was presented to moses which
was specifically a pattern regarding a
sanctuary that was in heaven
and we're told in exodus
chapter 25 verses 8 to 9
and let them make me a sanctuary
that i may dwell among them
according to all that i that i shoot
thee after the pattern of the tabernacle
and the pattern of all the instruments
thereof even so shall you make it so
here we clearly see that it wasn't just
the ten commandments that was given to
moses um it was also a pattern of a a
tabernacle that god was giving to moses
to be a system to point people to jesus
christ even in those days
and as we look at um we look at an image
here we can clearly see that this was a
blueprint you know this was a blueprint
that the children of israel were to
follow and it was specific people um
that god appointed to
to perform these tasks and building
these instruments and they couldn't do
it on their own god had to put his
spirit upon them
to perform this and how do we know that
there truly is
a heavenly sanctuary well we have to
continue to search the scriptures you
know study to show yourself approve
so line upon line priest upon precept
hear a little they're a little and as we
go to the book of acts um chapter 17
verse 24
uh it says god that made the world and
all the things therein seeing that he is
the lord of the heavens and earth
dwelleth not in temples made with hands
so what do you guys think about that wow
that's not on earth here
if it's not made with hands
right you could also pull that pull you
know some clues also in revelation where
john c john actually sees
um the ark of the covenant in heaven
again uh
usually i'm not gonna say usually
according to the bible every the the
system that's here presented on earth is
a pattern of what's
shown to us in heaven right and
specifically the sanctuary when we go to
the book of jeremiah we know that
god knows everything right
we know that god
had the plan of salvation put into place
even before we were even created from
the foundation of the earth right
jeremiah chapter 17 verse 12 says a
glorious high throne from the beginning
is the place of our sanctuary so the
sanctuary
was
present
even before man was even created even
before the earth was created
the very beginning so this is very very
important again as i said um regarding
the plan of salvation we can con
actually confirm this in first peter
chapter 1 verse 19 and 20 and it reads
it says but with the precious blood of
jesus
as of a lamb without blemish and without
spot who verily was for ordained before
the foundation of the world but was
manifest in these last times for you so
we can see that um this plan of
salvation was not an afterthought
god
knows everything the from the beginning
to the end and he he foresaw the fall of
man and the plan was already prepared
before we were even created before the
earth the foundation of the earth was
even laid
so let's specifically focus on the
sanctuary because within this sanctuary
are specific articles of furniture and
each article of furniture
is
detailed in a way where it can point you
to christ because that's the whole point
of the sanctuary
and as we go into the sanctuary the
first article of furniture which is
presented to us
is the altar of sacrifice
and for those who are not familiar with
what took place
uh with the altar of sacrifice it was
where the children of israel will have
to come you know on a daily basis to ask
for forgiveness of sin but without blood
there is no remission there's no
remissions of sins so obviously there
was multiple animals that you can bring
but we want to focus specifically on the
land because we're talking about jesus
christ
and again we we have
a situation where the people are going
before a priest
they're confessing their sins and having
to kill the lamb in that process
okay so how does this
point us to christ remember whatever
happened in the past there's nothing new
underneath the sun so what happened in
the past has to repeat itself within the
future leading us to christ
but we have an interesting situation
when we go in and read in the new
testament we're presented with a story
and the story revolves around john the
baptist
who is called the forerunner of christ
and as john the baptist
is baptizing people
he's already been told about the coming
of the person who would succeed him
remember john the baptist said i must
decrease and he must increase yeah yes
and
here we go we just want to sit here and
just picture this scene john the baptist
is baptizing it and everyone and then
all of a sudden
jesus comes walking down
towards this this area where john the
baptized
john the baptist is baptizing people
and he automatically is able to identify
who this person is that's coming towards
him
and the words are very interesting again
this points us back to the sanctuary
what animal had to be sacrificed or what
animal was sacrificed during the um the
altar of sacrifice
you have to have a lamb it had to be a
spotless
of the first year without blemish you
have to be of a certain kind of animal
so by other first year you mean it had
to be only or less than one year old yes
so it's a baby i mean this thing
this thing's really innocent yeah
innocent creature innocent
so john chapter 1 verse 29 says
the next day john see of jesus coming
onto him and saith behold the lamb of
god which takes away the sins of the
world again we just said earlier without
blood there's no remission of sins so
here we see
a lamb
symbolically representing jesus christ
is being portrayed in in such a way
where we can see that
christ would later fulfill
this sanctuary process in the future
being that lamb which would eventually
be slaughtered okay that's a powerful
word right there because can you imagine
back then
anything about like god yahweh you know
all the stuff i mean you need to really
stop and listen to
i mean he was saying you know the lame
of god
like what what are you talking about
yeah the you know the lamb you were
talking about for thousands of years
this is the land
and he has the
you know take away the sense of the
world i mean that was a powerful
statement right there like be quiet this
is the man you know he's the messiah and
you have to think about it also you have
to think about it also
every day you have people who are
constantly coming with a lamb
and they're just
sacrificing asking for the sense to be
forgiven next day it's the same thing
after a while becomes repetitive and you
become numb to it and this is why jesus
had become
[Music]
because it's a different effect
that it has on you when it's a person
dying and not an animal okay and you
know after a while just think about it
when you continue to do something over
and over again it just becomes normal
and it loses its significance and this
is what happened with the children of
israel and therefore christ had to come
and i i don't know about you guys but if
christ is the lamb i i don't know how i
feel about killing christ every
every time i sin oh buddy
oh man that's heavy that is heavy
what's interesting too i wanted to say
something
um like in the old testament the priest
the common priest would uh
because not all of israel can go inside
inside of the
sanctuary to sacrifice the land so the
common priest would um every morning and
every evening would sacrifice the land
for them and so on the third hour and
the ninth hour he would sacrifice the
lamb and that's exactly
when jesus christ was crucified he was
crucified in the third hour and he died
wow
really deep really deep
there's so much depth in the sanctuary
if we take our time to study
we can see the plan of salvation
manifold itself in in a way where we
would grow
to in increase with the love of god okay
um as we move on into the sanctuary we
look at the next article of furniture
you had first we just went over to alter
sacrifice but if we go directly straight
we'll
run into another uh piece of furniture
that's called the the labor flavor yes
and you you could you share with us
brother darius what exactly took place
at the labor so in order for the priest
to be able to enter into the sanctuary
they had to go through what we would
consider like a cleansing or a washing
ceremony
god had them come into his presence by a
certain way he commanded them that in
order for you to enter in here even
though i have chosen you and i've made
you my own inheritance
you must be cleansed you must wash away
and it symbolically um
symbolizes to us what we do now in the
act of baptism they were basically
cleaning themselves or allowing god to
wash away their filthiness before they
came into his presence
and and we could confirm that with
scripture
see it's just not our opinions
the word speaks for itself so there's no
need to doubt
as we go to matthew chapter three so i
got a quick question about that before
we move on so is it is it that um
baptism
and the labor are both symbolically uh a
symbol of sanctification is that is that
it where you are not you're justified to
the cross but you're sanctified by a
process that of is cleaning you christ
coming into your life and
getting rid of all that bad stuff in
your life so both those are essentially
i mean they're they're symbols of
themselves but they are um
they are
that understanding that this is a
cleansing you broke up a very very good
point
many people believe that the
altar of sacrifice is all that matters
because like brother brad was sharing
that the cross
crucified this is all people talk about
but if you pay close attention to this
method what god is actually doing is
he's pulling you closer into the
sanctuary christ died and he set the
standard all right this is your ticket
i've purchased a ticket for you to start
coming towards the sanctuary and what do
we do now in what we consider the new
testament church once we accept that
christ died for us
we show it through a public affirmation
of baptism we're preparing to enter in
and most people don't even realize god
is preparing to bring you into his
presence
in the sanctuary it's a step
by step process that truly never ends
and this is why understanding the
purpose and point of the sanctuary is so
powerful you brung it up earlier when
you said in in psalm chapter 7 77 13
god says
david says that thy way
when you think about someone's way
they're telling you this is how i am
this is who i am this is what i do
but then you have the caveat question of
what you asked about well
what about sin
sin didn't exist but you're saying that
this is how i am god is saying yes
the purpose of the sanctuary the reason
why i want to make it and to dwell
amongst you i have to show you who i am
and how i operate because there's such a
disconnect between man and god because
of sin so now i have to be the one that
comes in and invites you to where i am
so that you can begin to understand who
i am so that you're not fooled anymore
so that you can get a better
understanding of how i operate and what
i do and what i want to do for you you
don't have to listen to what others say
about me
you can see it in every article of
furniture until you ultimately get to
the most holy place where i dwell so
that we can have this one-on-one
conversation so that you will end up
being like the beloved disciple
john who understood this is who god is
he says yes the sanctuary is just
who i am you don't have to look at it as
just a way of salvation no this is who i
am and how i get down all the time
i'm god
this is how i move and this is what i
want you to see and if you don't
understand this you're going to be
deceived people can tell you anything
you'll believe anything because you
don't know me
the entire universe is looking
they're trying to get a grasp and an
understanding of who god is and god's
character this is why it was always like
this now god has an opportunity to flex
and to show this is how i am
this is what i do
come taste see that god is good come
check me out don't believe them try me
for yourself
this is what the sanctuary is about
that's awesome man i i think also i
think
a good word to explain that is you know
this um the way
is this is how i behave this is it right
and so now i wanted to ask a question
sorry if i'm interrupting but i want to
ask a question now
there are certain people that say when
jesus christ died on the cross he said
it is finished then that's it what do
you what do we say to that
question i don't believe that god can
lie can't lie that's number chapter 23
verse 19 that god is not a man that he
should lie nor the son of man that he
should repent have he not said and shall
he not do if christ said something i
believe it but that's not the problem
we need to dig a little bit deeper to
understand what exactly it is that he's
referring to he said that it is finished
what is the it will you pay close
attention as soon as christ died the
veil was torn
the wall of separation between man and
god he said it is finished so there is
no longer a need for us to have someone
else
come and stand and sacrifice for us we
have been given away the apostle paul
says that we are now able through christ
to boldly go before the throne of god
that's right because there's a priest
before that that would
it is finished now i'm the priest
i make that way for you so now you can
come
with me before the father and make your
petitions known
it is finished yeah he's the hype race
yes
so yeah um continuing in regards just to
confirm uh baptism through scripture we
see
uh matthew chapter 3 verse 11 says i
indeed baptize you with water onto
repentance but he that cometh after me
is mightier than i whose shoes i am not
worthy to bear he shall baptize you with
the holy ghost we see a reference to
baptizing um with water and
uh basically what that is is a
declaration of your relationship to the
to the mass public
about your relationship with christ
uh where are you standing
in the public's eye with with your
relation
pertaining to christ
unfortunately there's a lot of people
who just they get baptized just to get
baptized and i
um i know that the scriptures speak
about us being baptized of the water
and the spirit but obviously the spirit
usually comes first if you really think
about it because you're convicted and
that conviction leads you to baptism to
baptism right
and again and usually when the baptism
takes place
we're told
in matthew 28 verse 19 baptize them in
the name of the father the son and the
holy spirit
another reference to water if if you are
not familiar with the story i'm pretty
sure y'all are um
christ says speaking to the woman at the
well
okay
well-known
uh well-known story within the
scriptures probably one of my favorite
stories in the scripture why because
the first time that you're seeing christ
honestly reveal himself as the messiah
to a to to a woman you know and um or
just in general
and it goes on to say jesus answered and
said on to her if thou knewest the gift
of god
who it is that saith to thee give me to
drink thou would has have acts of him
and he would have given thee living
water that christ
is in fact that labor he is that living
water
and he's telling everybody listen come
come take a drink of this
okay come drink take take a drink of
this
as we continue to proceed within the
sanctuary right
we see
that there are other articles of
furniture now we have to enter into the
holy place
and as we enter into the holy place
there's three specific specific articles
of furniture
as we look to the right the first one
that we see is the table so show
okay
and there's so much stuff here just from
the imagery alone
that a lot of people fail um to see
and one of the things that i i i try to
reinsure people because today there's a
lot of books that are outside of the
bible
but if we understand the sanctuary we
could see that the sanctuary actually
points and tell you how many books are
in the bible how can we tell this well
on the table of shoe bread there were
two
layers of six
and if you put that together that's 66
how many books are in the bible 66.
what the bread of god
okay the word the word of god
66. so there should
be no doubt in regards to
any sources
that are outside of outside of the bible
and there's so many i can go on forever
um regarding them but pertaining to the
the showbread
in john chapter 6 verse 31 to 32 it says
our fathers did eat manna in the desert
as it is written he gave them bread from
heaven to eat then jesus said unto them
verily verily i say unto you moses
gave you not that bread from heaven
but my father giveth you the true bread
from heaven
obviously
what is the scripture talking about
jesus came here manifest in the flesh he
left
he left the heavenly kingdom and came
here and fed the people with the true
and not um
watered-down gospel
which was present presently at that time
being preached to
to everybody
and god and christ had to come here and
show them no this is what my word says
[Music]
we see in first timothy chapter 3 um
verse 16 confirming that christ came
here in the flesh paul was writing to
timothy and says and without controversy
great is the mystery of godliness god
was manifest in the flesh okay and
christ in the wilderness what's going on
in the wilderness
all right
he faces three temptations but one stuck
stuck out of them all pertaining to the
show bread
matthew chapter four verse four he says
man shall not live by bread alone but
what by every word that receiveth out of
the mouth of god okay so the bread is
being compared to the word of god
really significant
and then as we continue to go through
the holy place
and we we're looking north directly
north what do we have do you guys
remember
that's the altar because it's the author
vincent the altar of incense
and if we know our sanctuaries
okay and we know types and anti-types
we'll know that this
this altar of incense represent
represented prayer
and we can confirm that in revelation
chapter eight
verses one to three um
specifically verse three and it says
another angel came and stood at the
altar having the golden censer
and there was given unto him much
incense that he should offer it with the
prayers
of all the saints upon the golden altar
and what are we to to do today
these are these are two of three major
things that every christian should be
engrafted in and doing on a constantly
basis we just went over reading the word
eating the word up okay now we're going
into
the alter incense and obviously it
represents prayer and we're told in
first thessalonians chapter 5 verse 17
to pray with us to pray without ceasing
and we're not talking about being on
your knees 24 7.
you can have a conversation with god
while you're at work just speaking to
him in your mind
okay anyone else oh that's that's that's
it's dead on
because this was
the entire purpose of the sanctuary
is to gain the entrance or the the
entrant into a more personal and deeper
relationship with god each and every
single day
i would implore to anyone those watching
those of us sitting here that we should
be having a sanctuary experience
every day when you wake up you should be
willing to sacrifice yourself you should
be willing to allow the the holy spirit
and the blood of christ to wash you and
to make you clean for that day you
should be willing to to go
to the table of show bread and eat the
bread that's needed for that day's
battle praying and asking for god's help
and guidance and strength
and pleading for the holy spirit's
leading on that day's journey
the sanctuary is something that
literally should be a part of our lives
every day every moment
and that's that's the only way we're
going to get through this thing so it's
almost like we've come into the
sanctuary as a christian experience and
outside the sanctuary was our experience
that leads us to be a christian
and these
christian experiences in here are the
furniture it's not just like god's couch
exactly right exactly this is actually a
purpose for each one of these things and
this is the christian experience is
reading the word of god
prayer your prayer life and i suspect
there's another one too a third article
i'm excited
i also just want to say um that you know
for the people that say
when jesus christ died on the cross
that's it it's finished
how can we say
that we're you know growing in christ or
growing in the lord if we don't enter
into the holy place
and reading the word eating the word
and praying amen
because that's a very good point because
now you have to bring up this question
on the back end you said it earlier
but when christ says i am the way the
way to what
i am the way to what
that's the purpose of the altar of
sacrifice being the first thing i am the
way he is literally opening up the
pathway to the father
if you accept it
john chapter 3 verse 16 is the verse is
always quoted but we miss the
significance
for god christ isn't referring to
himself for god this is the father so
loved you
that he gave me
that if
you
would believe that he gave me you won't
perish
you'll have everlasting life he didn't
send me
to condemn you
but that through me
you might be saved
i am the way he's literally the door
that makes the way that's why he said if
you enter in in any other way you are a
thief and a robber he said i'm the
doorway to the sanctuary that's that's a
really interesting point because a lot
of people say well all i have to do is
say some magic words i'm saying
right i have to say i i was saved on
such and such a date and that that's why
i'm in heaven well if god says i am the
way believing in him means you are
following the way
and that's that's a lifetime process
that's it it's a lifetime problem
sanctification is a work of a lifetime
it's not a one-time thing no and one
scripture that comes to mind is amos uh
three
chapter three verse three
and it says can two walk together
together unless there'll be a greed
and
as we're going through the sanctuary we
have to be agreed with christ we can't
okay well christ is going one way and
we're all well i want to go back this
way it's a relationship yeah exactly
yeah exactly how you were saying that
that christ is the way
um and this is how he behaves it's
almost like
he's saying i'm the template i mean like
you can't you can't put something
through something if if you're not if
you don't if you don't fit in there
so you have to be like the template
right so that's that's all i wanted to
say no no that's powerful because
what both of you just shared think about
it if he's the template and he's saying
that you have to follow me and you have
to do it this way
let's be honest and let's just look at
this in the most simplest way
who goes into another person's house
and just goes room to room on their own
you have to have a guide and they show
you this is what's in this room
this is what i do here you don't just
bust through the front door and just
decide that you're going to go in there
and go your own way
when you're in another person's house
they have to open the door for you and
let you in and then they guide you from
room to room because nine times out of
ten
if you go into a person's house and do
what you want they're gonna kick you out
yeah and that's what god would do if you
say that i'm gonna go this way he's
gonna put you out you have to leave his
house you can't go into god's house and
do it the way that you want to a
different gospel yeah that's like a
different gospel you know i mean you go
there and just like
you know preaching the different gospel
or like you're learning different
gospels like oh i thought you know going
to
see god is you going this way no as
jesus is their way that's the problem
with another religion they don't want to
deal with that you know oh no he was a
good prophet oh that was a good teacher
that was a good day
but
yeah i mean i think that's this mess is
very cool because you know sometimes
it's like well i mean i just accept
christ like the first thing right
and that's it
and this thing about the old testament i
don't want to learn i mean it's kind of
old stuff but it's like no this is a
great message that we need to
be dealing with every day i mean wow
that's a great century
experience daily
yeah the bible says um search the
scriptures
for in them you think you have eternal
life
and what do they do they testify of
jesus christ john chapter 5 verse 39 you
know just to piggyback over amos um 3
verses 3 christ talks about the yoke and
what exactly is the yolk
okay so you it's usually two animals
that's yolked together that's right and
christ is telling you listen get on the
yoke with me all right
and if it's similar to amos 3 3 if
you're going the opposite way usually
you have to the animals have to agree
together in the way that they're they're
yoked together in the direction that
they're going to go
so um if you're thinking
and your mindset is opposite of christ
and you're going another direction how
can he work with us how can he work with
us and guide us through the sanctuary
um
pertaining to the candlestick we have
the next article of furniture on the
on the left side once you go into the
the holy place
and
this represents
uh light
and light beaming that
it has to go and spread throughout the
whole entire world okay
and we know that jesus christ is the
light i believe in uh john
yes john john speaks about jesus being
that light
and we know jesus is the
he's the hope of glory in us if jesus is
the hope of glory in us jesus that light
needs to be in us and it's not truly us
shining it's christ shining through us
okay and we're told in matthew chapter 5
verse 14 ye are the light of the world a
city that is set on a hill cannot be hid
so if you're in christ it's
people know
you can't hide it
you cannot hide it people will see
christ it's not so much what we're
saying nowadays that's what you do it's
what we're doing how are you living your
life okay and believe it or not people
are watching all the time all the time
people are watching so
it's not in your in your quiet time or
maybe when you're outside even when
you're home you know this this has to be
christ 24 7. okay we're we're we're told
also
regarding that light
matthew 28 verses 19 to 20 go ye
therefore and teach all nations
we have that light
now we are to go amongst the world and
spread the truth i don't know about you
guys but when i came to christ
i could not i could not stop speaking
about him
there was a love that just took over you
and you just you just couldn't stop
you know anybody here yeah yeah i mean
it's kind of like
the same you know same with me when i
first
started the ministry i could not stop
talking about christ i couldn't shut up
about him and it's kind of like it's
like a marriage you know
when you when you first
get married to your wife of course
you're going to talk about it all day
every day
so
something significant about this lamb
as we we see here the lamb as i believe
brother darius said it earlier it was
supposed to be presented in a certain
way yes okay it wasn't just supposed to
be any type of land okay this specific
lamb
in first peter chapter 1 19 says
but with the precious blood of christ
as of a lamb without blemish and without
spot what does that mean when we look at
at the um the situation revolving around
christ when he was on the cross
he was without sin
and he was without blemish remember what
they were told to do um to his legs but
they realized that he died he already
did he was the perfect sacrifice he had
no blemishes and he had no sin
and where this was fulfilled in john
chapter 19 verse 36 for these things
were done that the scripture pertaining
to um david um should be fulfilled a
bone of him shall not be broken and
again we see paul speak about this in
second corinthians
chapter 5 verse 21 for he have made him
to be sin for us who knew
no sin
who knew no sin jesus christ is our
example if he's capable of doing this
and we follow him through the sanctuary
we're capable of doing it too
amen and as we go into the most holy
place
we're presented with
the ark of the covenant and what was
significant if you care to share what
was significant about the ark of the
covenant well one of the biggest things
that was significant about it is because
this is where the high priest actually
met with god
the glory of god literally shined above
this
ark of the covenant
and what's so fascinating is when you
actually look at the reason why this is
transpiring in the book of revelations
we see that god literally sits between
the cherubims
so everything that he told moses he said
i want you to fashion this sanctuary
after the pattern that i'm going to show
you what god was basically doing was
making a pathway to his throne
for man to come and dwell before him
he even told moses how to make down to
the cubit of the the covering cherubs
that set there they were basically
covering the glory of god
and what's so significant about it was
not just simply the box or or the the
fact that it's god's throne is what
god instructed moses to put inside of
him
he told him to put in aaron's rod and
the significance of aaron's rod was you
had a lot of people that were saying
that we're
prophets and priests of god as well god
speaks to us
god said well i
make myself known to whom i make myself
known to and if you are really of me
i have a test for you lay your rods out
in the ones rod who blossoms
and it produces fruit
i've chosen him an orange rod blossomed
almond blossoms
off of a dead stick it brought some
almond blossoms and it produced almonds
and god said i chose aaron
so they put that in there
then
to represent how god feeds us through
the bread
through the manna they had to take a pot
of manna
to show that it was god that was not
only physically feeding them but he was
spiritually feeding them by giving them
his word they put that in there to show
the bread of life
and then finally the
the very character of god is placed in
there what we consider or what we call
the ten commandments showing god's uh um
justice his mercy his love his
unchangeable nature
was all set in there
to show the triune god the unity if god
manifested right there before humanity
before the universe
this was literally where god set
and the holy the holy spirit
is it's so fascinating
because
the illumination of the seven branch
candlestick
is god's spirit lighting the way
for the people to see this is where god
sits and the high priest would only
allowed to go in there once a year
for the rest of the people he was only
allowed to come in once a year and stand
before the presence of god
to basically have the sins remitted
it's just a fascinating thing when you
consider
what and why the alt the ark of the
covenant is
and what it points to the person is
basically standing before the king of
the universe
what's interesting are you gonna say no
what's interesting also is the in inside
the box also represents jesus christ now
remember
um jesus said i am the way the truth and
the life so the the rod is is what a
shepherd uses to lead the way right and
then of course um with psalm 119 verse
142 thy righteousness is an everlasting
righteousness thy law is truth that's
the ten commandments right and then of
course we have jesus christ being the
bread of life bread of life
right now amen
so um pertaining to the
um to where god sat
we know he sat on the seat but what was
the name of that seat
mercy the mercy seat so in hebrews
chapter 4 16 it says let up therefore
come boldly onto the throne of god that
we may obtain mercy and find grace to
help him in a time of need and
mercy or being merciful is one of god's
primary attributes regarding his
character and we can see that also in
exodus chapter 34.
um specifically verse 37 after
um moses acts as god to show him his
glory but god said okay well i'm going
to proclaim my name that's right and he
goes on to say it goes on to say we'll
start from verse six and the lord passed
by before him and proclaimed the lord
the lord merciful and gracious
long-suffering and abundant in goodness
and truth keeping mercy for thousands
forgiving iniquity transgressions and
sins and that will by no means clear to
guilty visiting the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children and upon the
children's children onto the third and
to the fourth generation
and i also found something that was very
interesting because again this this
sanctuary message is pertaining to us
okay so we have to
and we have to become merciful just like
god
okay
if we can't forgive our brothers and
sisters god can't forgive us forgive us
and in matthew chapter 5 verse 40 um 48
it says
be ye therefore perfect even as your
father which is in heaven is perfect
it's great right
but look how luke words it luke said
first
luke says in in in chapter 6 verse 36 be
therefore merciful
as your father also is merciful so here
we're being called
to be just like our father
just like christ
merciful
most like loving one another perfectly
like god would love other people right i
mean that's that's what i see between
the two words what's the perfect form
what's the most merciful thing you can
do
is love right so the perfect way is to
love
others
just how yeah yeah how god loves you
amen wow amen so that's that's the
experience of the most holy place that's
the most holy place that's where we all
need to get to and not and not just get
there and then fall back we need to get
there and stay there
in order to say that that was an
interesting point because we know that
jesus christ is the way right and it
points to who
the father right
and so and if we if you go to first john
4 and verse 8
it says god is love
and so we have to re
reciprocate and not just reciprocate but
also reflect that that type of love
and become also like the template wow
that's right
no man cometh to the father but
but by me says christ so the only way to
get to see the father face-to-face is
through your relationship with christ
and this is why he's guiding us to the
sanctuary so we could get to the throne
and when the father sees us who is he
seeing seeing christ he's seeing christ
he's seeing christ
another another scripture that comes to
mind remember we're talking about types
and anti-types to show you that the
plane of salvation was always there
in the book of numbers we're presented
with a situation where
it pertains to how they were to camp
around
the tabernacle
or the sanctuary
and we're told we're told in numbers
chapter 2 verse 2 every man of the
children of israel shall pitch
by his own standard with the a sign of
their father's house far off about the
tabernacle of the congregation shall
they pitch and i'm not going to go into
too much detail i'll paraphrase but each
tribe was set up
in a specific way intentionally by god
to point you to the cross and this is
just an image of what it
what it looks like
wow i never thought about it that way
this is what it looks like so the cross
was the foundation of the whole entire
bible the whole entire bible
all right and not only that
if we line up
if we line up the articles of furniture
that's right in the bible you can
actually see the layout of jesus christ
on the cross
[Laughter]
the we have the altar of sacrifice
which represents which is according to
the layout of the sanctuary is the nails
that was nailed into jesus's feet
and next we have the labor if we
remember while jesus was on the cross he
was pierced
in his side and what came out
water water water and blood
we have the table showbread
jesus was nailed on his
he was he was nailed on his left hand
and then we have the altar of incense
jesus died from a broken heart he died
from a broken a broken heart while he
was on a cross all right
we have the seven branch candlestick
jesus right hand was nailed and then
last we have the ark of the covenant
which was the the crown of thorns um
that pierced jesus's head
and um
i'm all i i love reading the closing
scenes
of jesus's life
and i remember i came across this
scripture and i started there with my
understanding of the sanctuary knowing
that the sanctuary is
in the form of a cross
i said to myself as i came upon the
scripture in mark chapter 15 verse 30.
it says the pharisees and the sadducees
the scribes they're all taunts in christ
while he's on the cross and they say
save thyself and come down from that
cross they had no idea what they were
saying oh my goodness
this was indeed a prayer because we know
that christ is going to leave the
sanctuary and what is the sanctuary in
the form of
a cross over the cross so christ is
actually going to come down from the
cross and answer the prayers of those
who taunted christ
and all of this
because you study the sanctuary
because we study the sanctuary so the
question now becomes
why is it that so many people do not
understand or do not see the
significance of the sanctuary
paul explains and paul explains it
he goes on to say in second corinthians
chapter 3 verses 13 to 15 and not as
moses which put a veil over his face
that the children of israel could not
steadfastly look to the end of that
which is abolished but their minds were
blinded
for until the day remain if that
the same
veil untaken away in reading of the old
testament
which veil is done away in christ but
even on to this day when moses is read
the veil is upon their heart and me and
we were talking about this earlier you
care to share what you shared with us
so the problem
that
israel of old had when moses was on the
mount with god he was sitting up there
with god
receiving the instruction that he needed
to give to the people when he came back
down moses had no clue he was just
elated he was just so happy to share
everything that god said but the people
were mortified because moses was
literally beaming with the glory of god
basically what the people told him was
we cannot bear god's glory we can't bear
to see the light of god
veil your face
cover up god's light so that we can
better receive or better accept what
you're saying wow so in the spiritual as
in the physical moses physically put the
veil over his face but spiritually
he was covering god's light
because the people couldn't bear god's
light and it's full they didn't want to
hear
or see god's light presented to them in
its fullness they wanted it veiled and
this is what paul references he said
that same veil remains on the heart when
people hear moses to this day moses was
speaking then they veiled him when you
read moses's word today to people the
veil is still there they don't want to
hear that light they don't want to
accept it like it's real sad
but nothing can happen unless it's
already happened so we see that in
scripture already
and we we also have a supporting
scripture just to back that up i'm
regarding the veil so we're talking
about today because obviously um the
veil is still on many people's eyes and
this is why they don't have a
understanding of the sanctuary
paul again says in second corinthians
chapter four verse three and four but if
our gospel be hid it is hid to them that
are lost why
in whom the god we're not talking about
the father or jesus christ
it's lowercase g we're talking about
satan
in whom the god of this world have
blinded the minds of them
which believe not least the light of the
glorious gospel of christ
who is the image of god should shine
onto them
so here we clearly see
um
that the enemy has a part in this
in fact it's so significant
that we know that the bible references
the the temple to being literal
and both spiritual
and our bodies are what
temple
so there's a battle going on
and this battle is explained
again by paul
paul's writings are sometimes
hard to be understood but if we read
line upon line precept upon precept it
should be a piece of cake
guided by the holy spirit we would
understand that there's a internal
battle going on and paul goes on to say
in 2nd thessalonians chapter 2 verses 3
to 4. let no man deceive you by any
means for that they shall not come
except there come a falling away first
and a man of sin be revealed the son or
perdition
who opposeth and exalted himself above
all the all that is called god
or that is worship
so that he
as god sitteth in our temples he's
trying to sit in our temples as god
showing himself that he is god so the
battle
is between
satan
and god and they're both trying to
gain access to our temple
paul is saying to the church at
thessalonica that
the second coming he says that that day
shall not come that's referring to the
second coming of christ unless there be
a falling away first from what from the
truth
and that man of sin be revealed
and he wants to come and sit on the
throne he wants to sit in the temple of
god
paul tells us in first corinthians
chapter 3 verse 16
and first corinthians chapter 6 know ye
not that ye are the temple of god so
this is where the enemy wants to come
and sit down in and as we've learned
from our discussion earlier
that
god is the one that orchestrates the
sanctuary because it leads back to him
so this battleground is right here
it's right here the enemy is trying to
be manifest and since we are born with a
sinful
nature or an inclination by default the
enemy is already
setting up shop
and we know that he's a master
manipulator and counterfeiter
but when we counterfeit something we
always counterfeit a truth
so paul tells us in hebrews 9 that we
have such a high priest that's standing
at the right hand of power which is
christ
so the enemy is basically trying to
counterfeit the work of what christ
would be doing and entering you into the
presence of the father
this is why christ comes to us in
revelation chapter three says behold i
stand at the door and not what door is
he knocking at if you're the temple if
you're the sanctuary he's knocking at
the door of the sanctuary he's like i'm
the high priest
you have to let me and satan's not going
to let him in only you can allow christ
to come into the sanctuary and do his
finishing work
only we can do this day by day and it's
so interesting that the things that you
guys talk about here are literally lined
up with that that you're trying to
explain to people and show them with
your led lives and and your different
documentaries that the enemy is setting
up shop here in your sanctuary
and he wants you to keep christ out he
can't let christ in he won't
you have to make the decision
if you hear his voice he says and will
open the door i will come in and just
like the high priest that we know of in
the sanctuary and the old testament he
came and cleansed the sanctuary he has
to come and clean out all the filth all
the the movies the music the money
changes the money all the things he got
to run out the money changers my my
father's house should be called a house
of prayer he's got to come in and
cleanse it
jesus is not simply the high priest of
heaven he wants to be the high priest in
you right now
he wants to come and clean you out
and that's also interesting what you
said about um about saying how we are by
default saying is
sitting at our throne yes and
now remember saiyan is influencing
influencing us to to do what to
transgress alone yes
and
you showed that picture a while ago when
you when you enter into the holy into
the to the sanctuary where does it go
from
east to west right it says in psalms 103
and verse 12 it says as far as the east
is from the west
so far had he removed our transgressions
from us
so that's what he's trying to do he
wants to sit in our thrones and want to
remove our transgressions from us
we don't see this message
the sanctuary message and they
christianity today
i'm telling you that because i was i'm
married with
a person that was not
the same faith
so
i used to go to her church
and you don't hear this kind of stuff
and what amazing study about
learning
of just not just to identify like oh
crazy was there crisis was there but
it's something like experience
like this is you know that's what we
presented this message because we want
this message in our life today
so if we experience the sanctuary
message daily
and we don't hear that kind of stuff in
our churches
how it's going to be our message or
gospel
it's going to be just
accept jesus it was right here number
one
or number two and number three but we
don't go to holy place or the most holy
place
where in the most holy places like
that's the character of christ we need
the character of christ and how we're
going to get to it
yes you need to eat the bread every day
you need to get you know what i'm saying
so uh to me it's like
if those popularity
uh you know mega churches or you know
the music or whatever
they don't present this message it is
and the bible the century message
i mean it's a it's a big big issue right
because uh uh
we need to we need to we need we need to
we need to share it in our and our
christian
and our christian faith you know in
christian churches right we do yeah this
is very unfortunate too because that's
where christ is trying to take us he's
trying to take us to the most holy
exactly
and a lot of us are stuck in the
in the courtyard the wilderness yeah the
wilderness the one of us yeah so
you should you think about it though
that's interesting
because if you're stuck in the
wilderness you can die there
people don't understand you have to get
inside of the sanctuary to live death
happens outside of the sanctuary you're
stuck out there you can die yeah that's
what happened to israel they were stuck
in the woods and they died
if you don't get inside of the sanctuary
that's psalm on 91 verse one if you
don't get in there you can't hide
you can't be hid from god's wrath
that's the ark you've got to get inside
of the sanctuary if you're outside of
there
you're going to die it's just like the
days of noah yes god is calling everyone
to get in the ark history is repeating
itself jesus pull you into the sanctuary
if you can get inside of the sanctuary
cause you gotta think about it the seven
branch candlestick the light of the holy
spirit he's god if you can just get
inside of there you're good
you're good if you can just get inside
of the sanctuary because let me tell you
baptism they accepted jesus like hey i
was safe three years ago you know what
i'm saying like in the you know outside
the century but what about autism both
just because you get baptized you're
gonna be
safe
no
yeah that's interesting too because why
why why do
the the the priests back then why do
they cleanse themselves not to just stay
there to go inside the sanctuary so that
was the purpose of it you know it's a
fascinating thing though when you
consider that like what brother alex was
saying when people say they believe in
christ and they get baptized what's the
first thing that they fall off from
studying the bible the table of
showbread it's right there that's the
first thing that people fall off from
they stop reading they stop praying
they're done
they haven't even entered into the
sanctuary they stop that baptism
they want to eat the show bread
they won't pray they can't get
illuminated by the holy spirit which
leads you into the most holy so those
are the three
but i would say
one the three most important articles of
furniture within the holy people i will
they don't only are the only ones but
they're very important because those are
the things that you have to do
on a consistent basis
read the word
pray have a relationship with god and
if you're reading the word you're not
going to be quiet you're going to the
holy spirit is going to
put it in you
to go and spread the gospel amongst you
know but let me tell you i had the holy
spirit i speak in tongues
that's the that's the thing about if i
had the holy spirit
so
you know enemies like you know what
you're speaking in times but guess what
that's confusion and and you know what's
interesting about that uh with the
people who come and they say that they
speak in tongues is
they they claim that this is a a
a fact that you have the holy spirit
but what does what did
christ say to
nicodemus
when they had the secret meeting you
don't know whether the wind comes or
goes so how can you pinpoint when you're
born of the holy spirit if christ
specifically said that you don't even
know when the holy spirit comes and goes
ouch
you know i think greg said it best greg
from uh bible flock box he said christ
is the most holy spirit filled and he
never spoke in tongue times wow
not once never good
i just want to bring a little attention
about like you know about the speaking
times like hey what about the holy
spirit you know because right now that's
christianity that's christianity that's
christianity right now
if you want to know more about school of
prophets these guys have a lot of
content on their youtube page can you
tell us a little bit more about about
your page yeah we deal with a lot of
like bible study videos and things like
that and
we have actually we have a few
uh documentaries that are out it's on
amazon prime and some of them are also
on on youtube um so if you guys search
school for profits on youtube you'll
find it there and also on amazon prime
you'll find it there and i'm sure you
guys will probably link everything oh
yeah
and then they have their separate
channels as well yeah i run a ministry
called bible impulse
where on thursdays we give studies to
youth
and um we've been getting great feedback
there's been a lot of people growing in
christ from that and we also give
studies on on sundays uh with with
adults so more a little more advanced
studies yeah and yeah very good
john what about you derek oh and i i
by god's grace um
lead
the youtube channel following christ 77
school for prophet south
we do we generally do have live streams
every um friday evening or sabbath
evening and everyone's welcome no matter
how old you are uh we got you locked
down by god's grace they're to help you
point you back to our main channel of
school for profits
right on as well by studios
you know where we are and we thank you
and thank patreons for helping us out
and we that little bit goes a long way
so we can bring you
more of this stuff
and we look forward to seeing you again
very soon
see you later
[Music]
hey denik here have you ever asked any
of these questions like
why does the old testament and new
testament god seem so different or what
does the bible have to say about sex why
do we have to wait for sex and super
mario or maybe who are 144 000 or why
does it seem like god doesn't answer my
prayer where clearly he says ask and it
shall be given to you etc yeah i've had
those questions too that's why you
should tune in every single wednesday to
our brand new podcast the little light
studios podcast in which we seek to
answer your most challenging bible
questions make sure you look us up and
hit subscribe on spotify apple podcasts
or anywhere else where you listen to
your podcasts we'll be there every
wednesday see you then
[Music]
you